it's now thought that more than 50
people were killed by a russian missile
attack on a train station in the east of
ukraine on friday as they tried to
escape the fighting
the situation in the south and east of
the country is increasingly desperate as
russian forces focus on the area with
ukraine saying they're trying to destroy
civilians
the red cross again sought to reach the
besieged city of mariopol this week as
people try to flee
all as more atrocities are discovered
around cave
now
pascal hunt leads the international
committee of the red cross in ukraine
and joins us now live from there
good morning uh mr hunt um
you're in western ukraine this morning
uh can you tell us uh anything about the
situation uh for those who are fleeing
the fighting
yeah good morning
yes indeed the situation for those
fleeing the fighting wherever it happens
it's an extremely difficult situation
fighting is taking place in
densely populated area
in cities
and these cities are being shelled and
we have seen the images we all these
images are really shocking even
outrageous
so you can imagine the level of despair
for these people
they're trying to leave they wait for
the train
they are being shelled so this is really
a dramatic situation
well you're referring to the uh
explosion
uh the missile attack frankly on the
railway station at kramertorsk what um
what are your people there telling you
about the aftermath of that
many uh consequences people are
even more in fear and despair this is
one of the problem
they do not dare to take the train
anymore so they are moving by car
they have difficulty to reach the the
hospital as well and as i speak the
international committee of the red cross
together with the german red cross we're
also trying to facilitate the evacuation
of people wounded uh
in the front line so yes the situation
is is even more difficult for the people
they were trying to leave and
and this is becoming really difficult
and we see them moving more and more uh
and taking the private cars and moving
by roads
oh so people there are now distrusting
uh rail as a mode of travel which
presumably must make
evacuation even more difficult and even
slower
i don't know if they are distrusting the
the the railway but can you imagine you
are waiting in a railway station and
then uh the shelling is happening so
they are really afraid so what we have
seen is that some of them were moving by
car maybe they will try again to reach
another railway station and continue to
move by train but i confirm that people
continue to flee the area yes
you also have uh
teams uh who have been trying to get to
mario paul um can you tell us if any of
your people
actually made it there and whether or
not they made it uh what you understand
has happened there now
our team tried for five days
to go to mario paul
and it's a difficult journey because you
have to cross the front line you have to
go through many many checkpoints
sometimes the people at the checkpoint
and the soldiers they're not aware of
your or
of your trip
and it's just an illustration on how
difficult it gets to have translated
into action you know the agreement
between the capitals and how difficult
it is for the order to tickle down at
the checkpoint so we went there with
buses
we moved we try we try again and again
but unfortunately the situation around
mario paul was too dangerous the
security conditions were not good uh the
security guarantees we got were were not
good either so at around 20 kilometers
from mario paul
we had to go back
we collected people on the road we
collected people in berlin
it was a long journey difficult journey
private cars were joining our convoy
under the flag of the red cross and
finally more than thousand people reach
zapurige
it may sound as a drop in the ocean
because the needs are much bigger the
situation is difficult there
people are there with no food no water
no heating system so yeah
it's really held there so i think many
more of such operation will need to take
place in in the coming days in the
coming weeks it is urgent
and we really
are in contact with the russian
authorities with ukrainian authorities
to ensure that safe passage is being
provided to to these people so they move
they can move freely and safely to to
much safer place
many of us the red cross itself has come
under some criticism uh internationally
and indeed from ukrainian politicians
uh themselves in fact one spoke about it
on this uh program in previous weeks
saying that you hadn't done enough to
protect refugees
and that you are too close
to russia
to do the job
that you're asked to do properly how do
you respond to that
i think it's a good illustration of the
difficulties
uh of being neutral there you know many
people understand
the difficulty of neutrality as of
either you are with us or you are
against us and we have heard that many
years and i think neutrality is more
than
taking side and taking side of the
victims and doing everything we can
in order to be close to the victims but
for doing so we need to discuss with the
parties to the conflict we need to
discuss with the ukrainian authorities
we need to discuss with the russians
ultimately they are responsible
of the behavior of the troops on the
ground they are responsible for
providing safety and security to the
population and they are responsible for
allowing humanitarian actors to go to
the front line to cross frontline
we will continue to do so but it's a
complex endeavor and we are in
discussion with the parties on that well
there's no question about the the icrc's
international reputation but you rightly
raise the issue of neutrality
um
how is it possible to be neutral
when it is pretty clear
that one side
is committing
uh
war crimes
and uh seems ready to commit further war
crimes as long as neutrality is
understood
as a mean to reach the victim
as a position of defending the victims
and being close to them
and
as a mean to achieve
more protection and assistance
then
i think it is easier to understand that
and our neutral position
was
we have positive example of that it's
because of being neutral that we were
able to cross front line and to try to
go towards mariupol
it's because we are neutral that we can
go
to front lines and hot places
so
the meaningfulness of neutrality
is translating into
concrete outcome for the population and
we will continue to do that despite the
criticism
but i have to admit that the criticism
we faced with respect to not doing
enough or
to favor one side or the other
is also preventing us to work
it is undermining our mandate it is
undermining our access to people
and i hope that this will stop because
this is not helping us to do our work
here
can you give an example of where that
happened presumably you mean
that in some circumstances
uh trust is broken down presumably with
ukrainians uh uh in the
uh red cross and that's making it
difficult for you to
rescue survivors to provide uh medical
and other help
and this is not about the ukrainian
authorities with whom we are in contact
every day and they perfectly understand
our position it's more
difficult to understand for the public
for the diaspora
where basically they don't understand
that we have to discuss with the
russians
so it's a matter of us being better to
explain what we are doing
and also in being better in
showcasing what what we are doing on the
ground and to demonstrate that when
people are receiving aid and assistance
this is also due to the neutrality of
the red cross
all right then if i may just finally ask
you about we talked about mario paul um
and we've seen a lot of what's been
happening in the south but we've also
seen some
terrible uh reports
of what has happened in the north around
kiev and for example in butcher
what is uh the icrc scene there
we have seen the same image
as everyone
we have been in bucha in irpil in
norgamel yesterday we were in chile
north of the country
and we see
basically the same image everywhere and
this is truly
appalling and heartbreaking we are
discussing with the people there we find
people in total despair
with no food no electricity no water no
eating system they have to go out in the
streets to make some
fire
and cook you know
these people were living in in
horrible conditions
so this is
the level of suffering that we are
seeing is just immense
and i don't recall having seen that in
recent history
we are collecting information we are
discussing with the people we do our
utmost to provide them with assistance
and whenever we see
uh
problems
uh
concerned
then we discuss as well directly with
ukrainians and with the russians on that
this is part of our bilateral dialogue
with the parties
to remind them of the
obligation under the geneva convention
and this is complementary to
the job that is done by
other groups that are coming vocal on
that journalists that are doing a good
job on the ground and we are
complementing this work
and we are discussing with the russians
on that as well
mr hon thank you so much for talking to
us this morning
you're welcome thank you very much